Set on a sprawling 150-acre estate,...
...Giraffe Manor is a free-roaming sanctuary...
...for several endangered Rothschild giraffes.
Giraffe Manor was built in 1932...
...and was modeled on a Scottish hunting lodge.
It wasn't until the 1970s,...
...however, that the manor became involved in giraffe conservation.
Located in the suburbs of Nairobi, Kenya,...
...the sanctuary was established in 1974.
Today, it's still run as a sanctuary with a successful breeding program...
...that supports Rothschild giraffes in the wild.
To help fund the project, the sanctuary owners also run a hotel...
...where guests like Robin can share a one of a kind breakfast...
...with the long-necked creatures.